bonsoir à tous merci de votre attention
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
jeudi la mise en place du nouveau
gouvernement les passations de pouvoir
n'ont pas traîné dans les ministères à à
percy nicolas sarkozy fixe ses priorités
emploi croissance et esprit de justice
mais les déclarations les plus attendus
ce soir sont bien sûr celle de jacques
chirac
la déroute des régionales le maintien de
jean pierre raffarin et la feuille de
route de la nouvelle équipe ce sera dans
un quart d'heure en direct de l'elysée
autre actualité de cette journée ce
rebondissement dans la sphère des
disparues de l'yonne la mort du gendarme
qui avait révélé la faire contre vents
et marées n'est peut-être pas dû à un
suicide
l'autopsié révèle la présence de deux
impacts de balles et puis le choc aux
états unis où les scènes de barbarie de
falloudjah en irak l'ouverture des
journaux télévisés
le crime ne restera pas impuni promet
washington
c'est parti donc pour le gouvernement
raffarin iii chaque ministre s'est
installé dans ses bureaux on va le voir
dans un instant mais d'abord ces
quelques mots du premier d'entre eux
jean pierre raffarin il était resté
silencieux depuis la débâcle de dimanche
dernier
il est apparu un peu éprouvé devant les
membres de la commission des droits de
l'homme à matignon et il a plaidé de
façon à peine voilée pour la poursuite
des réformes et pour un retour des
valeurs
ce n'est pas dans l'esprit de système ni
dans les fausses illusions que le
citoyen peut se retrouver rassurer fin
de citation les passations de pouvoir
maintenant traditionnel chassé croisé
les arrivants et des partants ambiance
et première intention alexandre kara
anthony masto mêmes cheveux même stature
que son prédécesseur michel barnier a
déjà le style des affaires étrangères à
peine le temps d'une poignée de main et
c'est dominique de villepin qui quitte
le quai d'orsay pour la place beauvau
le ministère de l'intérieur
décontraction et sourire de rigueur jean
louis borloo n'a rien changé à son style
pourtant jusqu'ici simple ministres
délégués le voici désormais numéro cinq
du gouvernement avec son prédécesseur
c'est une poignée de main protocolaire
et sans commentaire au jeu des chaises
musicales ministériel françois fillon
prend les rênes de l'éducation et c'est
à pied qu'il se rend à son nouveau
ministère
on n'a pas le temps d'être triste
mais pour l'instant voudrait marché
provoque sur le perron l'équipe sortante
attend les nouveaux locataires là encore
il faut jouer des coudes
luc ferry par xavier darcos reste alors
quand on sait que leurs relations furent
difficiles pendant deux ans on décèle
l'ironie de certains à dieu bon courage
à bientôt
luc ferry et sa femme marie caroline
s'en vend beaucoup d'applaudissements et
des larmes aussi pour un au revoir aux
ministres de la société civile premier à
s'installer c'était tôt ce matin avant 9
heures nicolas sarkozy le nouveau
ministre des finances qui a quitté
l'intérieur sous les applaudissements
michaël darmon annick rivoire
scènes d'adieux place beauvau nicolas
sarkozy qui aurait préféré rester à
l'intérieur
quitte le quartier de l'elysée une heure
plus tôt dominique de villepin déjà
soucieux de corriger son image distante
arrivent à pied
plus qu'une simple passation de pouvoir
le petit peuple du ministère a
l'impression de tourner une page
j'ai vécu ici avec vous deux années qui
compteront beaucoup dans ma vie le
travail qu'on a fait ensemble
je voudrais vous le dédié puis c'est le
mot sur le successeur villepin le très
proche de jacques chirac
celui qui jouait les intermédiaires
qu'on le contact a été rompu entre
l'elysée nicolas sarkozy pour vous dire
vous avez un grand ministre de
l'intérieur et pas simplement par la
taille
nicolas sarkozy a parlé d'honneur de
fierté
c'est les premiers sentiments que j'ai
ressenti en entrant dans cette cour et
11 ans après voilà nicolas sarkozy de
retour à bercy là où sa carrière
ministérielle a débuté au budget le chef
d'entreprise francis mer rend aux
politiques la citadelle de l'économie la
méthode pour l'instant ne change pas il
faut des résultats et la culture du
résultat je la demanderaient
l'administration de bercy croissance et
emploie les mots la méthode l'équipe
nicolas sarkozy change de territoire
mais par des trajectoires
en tout cas cette nomination à bercy a
fait un heureux ernest antoine seillière
président du medef
il évoque à zinedine zidane au finançons
les coûte 700 mines entrepreneurs du
medef apporte à raffarin iii beaucoup
d'attention et pense que l'équipe
nouvellement composer avec ce buteur se
saisit dan en quelque sorte de l'équipe
qu'est sarkozy aux finances nous donnent
l'espoir que nous pourrons avoir plus de
croissance donc plus d'emplois voilà pas
de changement en revanche pour michèle
alliot marie après avoir été confirmé à
son poste de ministre de la défense elle
a réservé son premier déplacement aux
soldats français déployés au kosovo et
ce quinze jours après les incidents de
la mi mars entre serbes et albanais
rappelons que deux mille neuf cents
hommes sont stationnés dans la province
cette journée a aussi été l'occasion de
découvrir les jeunes pousses entre
guillemets de ce gouvernement la plupart
sont des élus de fraîche date inconnue
au plan national et les nuques emilie
lançant un faussaire d'alain juppé avec
qui il a travaillé à matignon eric
woerth attendait son heure depuis
longtemps il devient à 48 ans secrétaire
d'état à la réforme de l'état issu lui
aussi de la jeune garde de l'ump quasi
inconnu hier xavier bertrand est
aujourd'hui hyper sollicitées à 39 ans
il récupère le dossier explosif de
l'assurance maladie
elle a un peu le trac à quelques minutes
de son entrée en fonction il ya des
choses à faire dans sa limite
ça limite la patiente mari annonçant
devra faire avancer un dossier cher au
chef de l'état celui des handicapés à
peine nommé est déjà dans le bas
secrétaire d'état à l'agriculture sous
la tutelle d'hervé gaymard
nicolas font ici assister dès ce matin
au congrès de la fnsea
il a presque l'âge de sa fonction à 35
ans laurent hénart s'occupera de
l'insertion professionnelle des jeunes
il est le benjamin du gouvernement
tous ces novices ont un point commun ils
sont membres de la boussole un club de
réflexion proche de l'ump
créée au lendemain de la présidentielle
de 2002 un gros plan maintenant sur la
nouvelle ministre de la famille et de
l'enfance elle s'appelle marie josée roy
gueller députée maire d'avignon c'est à
ses côtés que jacques chirac avait
déclaré sa candidature en 2002 véronique
saint-olivier mme richard avec notre
bureau de marseille
marie-josée rouag ne sait plus où donner
du portable
la nouvelle ministre de la famille est
attendu à paris les dossiers urgents
sous le bras la maire d'avignon quitte
sa ville où elle avait joué il ya deux
ans à célèbre duo avec jacques chirac
le président va t-il déclaré sa
candidature
oui je suis candidat 17h paris dans un
bureau ou encore dr premières
impressions moi je suis femme
carriériste jeu
je fais les choses au coup de coeur
chiraquienne depuis toujours député du
vaucluse
marie josée roy connaît le terrain mère
de famille elle prône l' écoute
aujourd'hui elle ne cache pas son stress
mais elle se lance on va essayer de dire
que mon dieu rien n'est perdu il ya
encore du temps devant nous il ya des
choses qui ont été faites qui n'ont pas
forcément été bien comprise pas de temps
à perdre déjà la nouvelle ministre frank
contact avec ces nouveaux collaborateurs
ils ont pensé à la tasse de thé pour un
court moment de détente ce n'était pas
vraiment superflu effectivement c'est
certainement pas cet impressionnant
voilà c'est très et puis cette journée a
été l'occasion pour les ministres
chargés des dossiers les plus chauds de
donner le ton face à des syndicats qui
met déjà la pression enseignement
recherche assurance maladie les
premières urgences
jeff vite imbert patrick démunis on veut
des actes pas des discours le nouveau
ministre de l'éducation est tout de
suite mis dans le bain mais ce matin
avec cette manifestation à paris de
futurs enseignants et de personnels
techniques le 7 avril
les principaux syndicats appellent à une
grande journée d'action
françois fillon qui succède à luc ferry
très contesté s'est donc fixé une
priorité du tablir une relation de
confiance avec tous les personnels de
l'éducation nationale de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche est
naturellement avec une méthode dont je
ne me suis jamais départi qui est celle
de l'écouté et du dialogue social
encore un baptême du feu sous la
pression pour françois d'aubert une
manifestation de chercheurs hier à paris
comme il y en a eu beaucoup ces
dernières semaines les chercheurs
protestent contre la suppression de 550
postes et une baisse générale des
crédits qu le nouveau ministre se veut
rassurant
une réponse qui sera apporté en termes
de moyens pour les laboratoires de
moyens en hommes jeunes à mon tour c'est
le dossier le plus brûlant et c'est une
médecine de choc que le docteur philippe
douste blazy qui succède au docteur
mattei va devoir pratiquer 11 milliards
d'euros de déficit pour l'assurance
maladie en 2003 y aura-t-il une hausse
de la csg un ajustement des cotisations
tout doit être bouclé avant l'été
il faudra bien sûr partager les efforts
pour tous propos chez les bénéfices donc
la justice et partage et socialement les
efforts claude roy a fait jean jacques
aillagon enfin passé le pouvoir à renaud
donnedieu de vabres et surtout repasser
au nouveau ministre de la culture le
dernier dossier chaud qui attend le
gouvernement
le conflit des intermittents du
spectacle de nouvelles manifestations
sont prévues le 19 avril
renaud donnedieu de vabres dit vouloir
renouer le dialogue est à noter ce signe
d'apaisement le gouvernement a décidé de
reporter l'examen par le conseil d'état
du projet de loi sur le changement de
statut d'edf gdf une mesure en tout cas
qui paraît hautement symbolique
un mode politique encore avec la
confusion ce soir en corse comme
ailleurs l'assemblée territoriale ce
alice est pour la première fois
aujourd'hui depuis les élections la
gauche dispose d'une majorité relative
en sièges mais c'est finalement l'ump
camille de rocca serra qui a été élu
président grâce aux voix des
nationalistes et du coup il a aussitôt
présenté sa démission il faudra revoter
impossible donc de dire à l'heure qu'il
est si la collectivité territoriale sera
gouvernée par la droite ou par la gauche
et puis les élections des présidents des
conseils généraux ont confirmé le
basculement à gauche de dix départements
le ps en préside désormais 48 soit la
majorité voilà pour cette page politique
et je vous rappelle que dans 5 minutes
maintenant jacques chirac s'exprimera en
direct de l'elysée une intervention bien
sûr très attendu en attendant les uns
que les autres informations à retenir de
cette journée est d'abord je vous le
disais ce coup de théâtre dans la sphère
des disparues de l'yonne l'affairé mille
louis nos révélations ont été confirmées
par la justice le gendarme qui a révélé
l'affairé qui a été retrouvé mort en
1997 ne se serait peut-être pas
suicider l'autopsié relance la thèse du
meurtre
and gas burget valérie ermite jean
françois remy question jambert était un
bon gendarme et un gendarme sans doute
un peu trop zélé quinze années durant il
a enquêté recouper piste emile louis
convaincu que l'homme détenait le secret
de ces jeunes filles qu'on appelait les
disparues de l'yonne convaincu aussi de
dysfonctionnement majeur dans l' enquête
judiciaire
il l'avait écrit des 84 dans ce
procès-verbal restée lettre morte
jusqu'en 97 ou l'instruction semblait
relancé mais à quelques heures de son
audition par le juge christian jambert
été retrouvé sans vie suicider at-on dit
dossiers classés jusqu'à aujourd'hui
autopsie du corps concordants éléments
qui remettent en cause le suicide
les constatations du médecin légiste
laisse à penser qu'il y aurait deux
orifices d'entrée de projectiles au
niveau de la tête de la victime
il faut nous expliquer comment on peut
se mettre deux balles dans la tête de
d'angles différents et comment surtout
on peut ne pas le constater quand on
découvre le corps du gendarme jambert et
quand on donne le permis d'inhumer deux
balles qui pourrait être tout deux
mortels sait-on aujourd'hui et pas de
tout petits à l'époque et puis ce
dossier encore domjan d'air ne se
séparait jamais et qui a disparu
sur la fin il se sentait menacé la wii
blavet dis bien clairement il m'avait
fait comprendre que on avait essayé de
de l'agresser bon il m'avait montré des
marques au niveau de son visage
je vais poser des questions il m'a bien
fait comprendre qu'il ne voulait pas
faire deux tentatives de suicide
aujourd'hui les enfants du gendarme
jambert réclament l'ouverture d'une
nouvelle instruction pour assassinat
justice encore avec ces couacs en série
au tribunal de bobigny deux évasions en
24 heures un homme soupçonné de trafic
de drogue
c'est en effet échappé à son tour la
nuit dernière il aurait subtilisé les
clés d'un gardien avant de sauter par la
fenêtre d'une salle d'audience hier
c'est un spécialiste des braquages de
poids lourds qui avait faussé compagnie
à son juge d'instruction qui répondait
au téléphone
une enquête administrative a été ouverte
à l'étranger le choc aux états unis où
certains parlent déjà de syndrome
somaliens les scènes d'horreur en irak
que nous évoquions hier ont été
diffusées par les télévisions
américaines
la maison blanche annonce la maison
blanche dénonce des attaques barbares et
méprisable à washington avant chalvron
arundel le titre dit des jaloux
sauvagerie dans l'art et le présentateur
du journal d'anna razer annonce la
politique de sa chaîne sur civière après
y avoir longuement réfléchi dit il et en
essayant d'être responsable nous avons
décidé ceux ci les images seront donc
diffusés mais brouille est suffisamment
clair toutefois pour être plus
évocatrices la plupart des autres médias
avaient fait le choix de ne pas montrer
les corps choix conforme aux souhaits de
la maison blanche
j'espère que tous les médias se
montreront responsable et dans leur
couverture la presse ce matin n'a pas
ces pudeurs et les photos sont
difficilement soutenable l'émotion est
bien sûr considérable aux états unis
maintenant quelles conséquences cela
aura-t-il difficile à dire entre ceux
qui voudraient envoyer l'irak au diable
et l'administration qui dit qu'il faut
t'y restait plus que jamais oui il faut
rappeler que la ville de falloudja est
l'une des places fortes des opposants
armés à la présence américaine est
apparemment les actes de sauvagerie
perpétré hier ne suscite aucune émotion
particulière au sein de la population
envoyés spéciaux bertrand cocq gilles
jacquier
les policiers de falloudja sont surtout
connus pour leur passivité face à la
guérilla
hier lorsque les américains ont été
immolé et leurs corps exhibés par les
rues ils ne sont pas intervenus
moi j'étais de reco ce défaut celui ci
comme la plupart de ses camarades en
aparté les hommes en uniforme n'hésite
pas à plaisanter sur ce qui s'est passé
hier est devant la caméra ces visages
gravés propos de circonstance
les habitants de falloudja ne se
réjouissent pas tous de ce qui s'est
passé
certains ont même fermé leurs magasins
mais sept autres policiers penchent
plutôt pour une vengeance récemment dit
il les américains avaient tué des civils
lors d'une opération depuis un an
falloudja et le cauchemar des américains
situé en plein triangle sunnite
c'est un des bastions de la guérilla les
américains ont fait bien pire que nous
dit ce passant ils sont entrés dans les
mosquées où ils ont piétiné le coran
l'opération d'hier nous a redonné la
fierté nous avons venger nos morts et le
commerçant qui affiche ses préférences
se fiche pas mal de savoir que paul
brenner l'administrateur américain a
promis d'être impitoyable avec les
rebelles de falloudja émotions et
l'horreur provoquée aux états unis par
la mort des quatre américains et le
traitement barbare infligé à leurs
cadavres sont des sentiments tout à fait
étranger aux habitants de falloudja pour
la plupart d'entre eux ce qui s'est
passé hier n'est qu'un épisode de plus
de la vendetta qui les oppose depuis un
an aux américains voilà il est
maintenant 20h15 à quelques secondes
près jacques chirac s'apprête donc à
répondre aux questions quatre jours
après le second tour des régionales et
au lendemain de la présentation du
nouveau gouvernement tout de suite
direction le palais de l'elysée mais le
président m'ont soir merci de nous
accueillir avec patrick poivre d'arvor
alors tout simplement voilà à deux
reprises lors des deux tours des
élections régionales les français ont
exprimé très fortement leur
mécontentement et puis il ya 48 heures
vous avez à nouveau choisi jean-pierre
raffarin comme premier ministre et
beaucoup de français se demandent
aujourd'hui si vous avez bien entendu et
compris leur message
oui j'ai écouté attentivement et j'ai
entendu le message de nos compatriotes
beaucoup d'entre eux ont en effet comme
vous le dites exprimé des inquiétudes
des impatiences des mécontentements en
fait et le gouvernement doit tenir
compte de ce message il doit d'en tenir
compte
d'abord en étant plus encore que par le
passé en offensive sur deux domaines
essentiels à la vie de la nation
l'emploi et la croissance
ensuite en ayant plus que jamais présent
à l'esprit une exigence fondamentale
qu'est la justice sociale et qui doit
être en quelque sorte le point de
passage obligé de toutes les réflexions
concernant l'action l'évolution des
choses et enfin en marquant très
clairement sa volonté d'ouverture et de
dialogue
ouverture et dialogues qui sont il faut
le dire des qualités qui ne sont pas
traditionnellement dans la culture
française qui doivent être développées
alors à partir de là des corrections
d'actions sont peut-être nécessaire nous
y reviendrons et vous qui intervenait ce
soit en première ligne et non pas lui
c'est peut-être que vous le considérez
un peu comme votre directeur de cabinet
certains observateurs ont parlé de
fusible ou de premier ministre avec un
cdd trois mois juste pour affronter des
réformes impopulaires et des élections
européennes plutôt mal parti monsieur
vers l'avant méfiez-vous des clichés
j'ai fixé un cap j reviendrons j'ai fait
le choix de la constance de la
détermination et de l'action en nommant
jean pierre raffarin à la tête d'une
équipe remaniée renouvelé et qu'ils
croyaient le bien sera entendre et a
entendu le message
compte adresser beaucoup de français et
monsieur poivre noir j'ai estimé en
conscience en conscience que monsieur
raffarin et tête
amen compte tenu de son expérience de
tirer ses conséquences et aussi de
poursuivre l'action
parce que l'homme est de qualité parce
que naturellement c'est un homme de
qualité sinon je ne l'aurais pas choisie
et je ne l'aurais pas renommée mais
aussi parce que il connaît bien la
france et les français
et il est tout à fait en harmonie avec
le cap que j'ai fixé en 2002 et qui est
un cap kit orienté vers deux objectifs
le premier objectif c'est de redonner
des fondations solides à la république
d'où l'action pour restaurer ou rétablir
l'autorité de l'état et la sécurité des
citoyens pour refuser toute forme
d'intolérance ou d'exclusion
le grand problème pour la france
d'aujourd'hui pour réaffirmer et faire
respecter les valeurs républicaines au
premier rang desquels se trouve
l'égalité des chances et la laïcité
le deuxième objectif étant bien entendu
de se mettre en mesure d'assumer les
évolutions qu'exige l'évolution du monde
et dont la france ne peut pas
s'abstraire soit pas disparaître ou à
assumer de graves difficultés
ces évolutions notamment économiques et
sociales voilà les deux objectifs que
j'ai fixé le cap que j'ai fixé dès 2002
et qui reste le même petite précision la
question est effectivement il n'est pas
là pour trois mois jean-pierre raffarin
quel que soit le résultat des élections
européennes
il y aura pas de remaniement il restera
pour que ce soit clair mais mme chabot
on ne nomme pas un gouvernement pour une
durée déterminée
on nomme un gouvernement pour atteindre
des objectifs c'est bien dans cet esprit
que j'ai donné ce gouvernement est au
tout petit précision aussi pour quelque
chose soit claire vous n'avez pas choisi
jean-pierre raffarin parce que vous ne
vouliez pas nicolas sarkozy
je comprends très bien le goût qu'on
peut avoir pour la polémique
ça fait partie j'allais dire des scories
mais aussi des plaisirs de la démocratie
et nicolas sarkozy est un homme de
grande qualité qui a parfaitement réussi
dans une mission essentielle qui lui
avaient été confiées et qui n'était pas
facile à tous égards a tout à fait
légitimement sa place dans une autre
mission essentielle aujourd'hui qui est
celle d'assumer la politique économique
et financière de notre pays
mais il est un jour premier ministrable
vous n'avez pas de problèmes majeurs
avec lui je n'ai pas de problème avec
lui avec l'unité sarkozy je lis parfois
là les échos si vous là c'est tout à
fait normal et je veux dire que je n'y
reconnais jamais la réalité des choses
alors justement si sûr nicolas sarkozy d
des gens sont dits bon il a bien réussi
en effet place beauvau il y avait un
deuxième ministre des très populaires
qui était dominique de villepin qui a
porté donc avec panache la parole
française à l'étranger
et ces deux-là change de poste ça
correspond à quoi aux exigences du jour
était évident que une nouvelle impulsion
devait être donné sur le plan économique
même si monsieur francis mer avait
assumé ses fonctions avec une très
grande qualité une très grande autorité
je tiens à lui rendre hommage mais j'en
avais besoin d'un changement d'une
impulsion nouvelle
et c'était vrai également dans
autres ministères j'ai choisi monsieur
de villepin vont assumer les fonctions
tout à fait essentiel de ministre de
l'intérieur je suis persuadé qu'ils les
assument qu'ils les assumera avec la
qualité qui m'a mise à assumer ses
précédentes fonctions
si vous disiez vous continuez monsieur
le président en 2002 après le choc du 21
avril c'était un gouvernement de mission
qui avait été mise en place que ce qui
n'a pas marché c'est toujours notre et
ce gouvernement a fait beaucoup de
choses
nous avons connu une longue phase
d'immobilisme
il était tout à fait évident que la
france avait besoin d'un certain nombre
d'évolutions d'adaptation de réformes et
que l'on repoussé indéfiniment ses
réformes
probablement parce qu'elles sont
toujours difficiles à faire et qu'on
redoutait les conséquences que cela
pouvait comporter sur le plan purement
politique et il fallait les faire et le
gouvernement de monsieur raffarin
assumer cette responsabilité difficile
l'exemple typique est celui
naturellement de la réforme des
retraites c'est vous que si on n'avait
rien fait avant 2020 on aurait été
obligé pratiquement de diminuer par deux
le diviser par deux nos retraites ce qui
était tout à fait plus on avançait dans
le temps plus la réforme était difficile
et plus les résultats étaient compromis
entre autres choses bien d'autres
réformes ont été faites
vous savez quand on change un peu les
choses et il ya toujours des surtout
dans un pays comme la france mais c'est
vrai dans toute l'europe pour regarder
ce qui se passe on chez tous nos voisins
ils sont soumis au même traitement pour
les mêmes raisons ils les assument
peut-être un peu mieux encore que je
n'en suis pas sûr parce que là la
sanction électorale a été très forte
quand même 24 régions où 25 régions sur
26 à 0 j ai entendu
ça tient à ce mécontentement que
j'évoquais mais quand vous regardez le
nombre des français qui ont approuvé
l'action du gouvernement par rapport au
nombre des français qui l'ont
désapprouvé la différence n'est tout de
même pas considérable et le problème
n'est pas là il y a une responsabilité
générale du gouvernement quel qu'il soit
à l'égard des évolutions qui s'imposent
à notre pays dans tous les domaines
sinon la france sera sur le bord de la
route elle ne suivra pas la france est
un pays qui a des atouts considérables
qui a une voix qui porte dans le monde
qui est considéré respecter c'est
indiscutable naturellement si elle veut
conserver cette situation qui lui permet
par ailleurs de défendre ses valeurs et
ses intérêts de façon efficace il faut
aussi qu'elles s'adaptent et les
adaptations
c'est toujours un peu douloureux dont le
gouvernement doit être convaincu
c'est d'une part qu'il faut poursuivre
l'action d'adaptation de notre société
au monde moderne mais qu'il faut le
faire je l' ai dit tout à l'heure et je
le répète en ayant en toile de fond
permanent donc dans le regard en
permanence l'exigence justice sociale
qu'à juste titre les français
considèrent qu'il n'ya pas assez ancien
pour reprendre la question une deuxième
fois d'arlette chabot qu'est-ce qui n'a
pas marché dans le gouvernement
précédent
est-ce que par contre c'est les
ministres issus de la société civile luc
ferry jean jacques aillagon
six maires qui ont façonné dans les
chansons il ya toujours beaucoup
d'injustices forcément il ya toujours la
descente a devancé campione progression'
elle à la politique toujours c'est la
politique contrairement à ce que
beaucoup de gens pensent ou croire c'est
également un métier c'est également une
vocation qui exige une formation il faut
avoir la foi la vocation et la formation
c'est la raison pour laquelle des
changements parfois s'imposent ils sont
souvent douloureux regrette a peut-être
injuste mais c'est d'intérêt général qui
doit primer et ce n'était pas que ce
gouvernement au fonctionnement difficile
sociale oui difficile social pour
beaucoup ce gouvernement est apparu
comme un gouvernement qui donnait plus
déjà aux privilégiés ça a été vécu comme
ça les baisses d'impôts pendant qu'en
même temps il y avait des chômeurs qui
était radis de l'uni dit que
l'allocation spécifique de solidarité
était réduite et on a dit ben voilà
c'est l'injustice sociale y avait plus
de sécurité dans deux mais la vie est
moins dans la déraison et dans toute
critique il ya toujours un fond de
vérité et je ne crois pas que l'on
puisse dire qu'on a favorisé les riches
au détriment des autres ce qui en
revanche était essentiel c'est de
libérer les énergies et de faire en
sorte qu'en france où soit incité à
travailler à investir à produire à créer
des emplois et nous arrivions à une
situation où hélas le découragement
exister chez les forces vives les plus
est plus essentielle à la nation et on
le voyait notamment au travers du nombre
d'entreprises de capitaux de
travailleurs qui partait à l'étranger
ça c'est pas possible c'est une
situation qui ne peut pas durer
et donc il était essentiel non seulement
pour maintenir notre capital de
croissance mais également pour maintenir
l'espoir chez ceux qui veulent investir
ou s'investir pour créer et créer de la
richesse et donc de l'emploi et donc du
progrès social
il fallait prendre un certain nombre de
mesures elles ont été prises alors comme
je voulais je vous le dis à l'instinct
il ya toujours un fond de vérité vous
avez cité la ss question spécifique des
seniors vous avez raison
et là il n'ya probablement une
correction à faire il
circonstances qui auraient peut-être dû
être mieux prévu qui a fait que sont
arrivés ensemble au même moment
d'une part la réforme indispensable de
l'unedic qui était en train d'être en
faillite et que les partenaires sociaux
ont décidé ça c'était pas du tout de la
responsabilité du gouvernement
partenaires sociaux ont décidé une
réforme de l'assurance chômage dans le
cadre de l' une éthique et parallèlement
les la prestation donnée à ce qu'on
appelle les travailleurs en fin de
droits l'appel la ss qui elle relève de
la responsabilité du gouvernement
cette réforme a été faite au même moment
et cette simultanéité qui n'a pas été
suffisamment coordonnées s'est traduite
par les difficultés que vous évoquez à
juste titre qu'ils ont été très durement
ressentie par un certain nombre de
travailleurs ou de chômeurs dans notre
pays
mais vous aviez juste difficultés parce
que au parlement est allée des gens qui
différerait genou dick
j'ai écouté ce qu'ont dit les français
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
demandé au gouvernement de suspendre la
mise en oeuvre de la mesure relative à
la ss la loi de mobilisation pour
l'emploi que prépare actuellement le
ministre de la cohésion sociale monsieur
jean louis borloo doit permettre de
reprendre les choses est dans une
logique d'ensemble et cela avec un
objectif principal qui est de mieux
aider de mieux accompagner les chômeurs
les gens qui sont au chômage dont le
retour à l'emploi pour retrouver un
emploi une activité
et c'est dans ce contexte qu'il faudra
régler le problème de la ss j'ai donc
demandé qu'on suspende la mise en oeuvre
de cette plainte de cette mesure est ce
que vous diriez oui c est ce que vous
diriez comme le numéro 3 de votre
gouvernement françois fillon que ce qui
s'est passé dimanche c'est un
21 avril à l'envers je me suis toujours
des formules est ce qu est ce qui a pesé
aussi donc peut-être de ce
mécontentement des français il ya le
premier des problèmes aussi sociaux qui
n'ont pas été réglés ou des conflits les
intermittents 10 buts
oui on va en venir la réforme est par
exemple les intermittents du spectacle
c'est un conflit qui a duré quand même
temps on n'a pas compris que vous
pensiez peut-être pas plutôt sur les
demandes des chercheurs alors qu'en même
temps on donnait aux restaurateurs ce
qui était pas forcément illégitime et là
aussi on a ce sentiment peut-être chez
certains français qui avaient
d'injustice vous soulevez trois
problèmes qui méritent effectivement
réponse les intermittents du spectacle
au départ une décision prise par les
organisations compétentes dans le cadre
de l'indemnisation du chômage pour faire
face à un déficit considérable du régime
des intermittents dont la conséquence
est exclue régime était en faillite et
que le déficit était pris en charge
nécessairement par l'ensemble des autres
travailleurs ce qui a pu sembler
inadmissible inacceptable par les
responsables syndicaux du professionnel
et honnêtement mais pas sa vie
honnêtement je crois qu'ils ont eu
raison
en revanche on ne sait pas me
semble-t-il
on n'a pas pris suffisamment conscience
du la spécificité française dans le
domaine de la culture nous sommes des
défenseurs acharnés
vous le savez sur le plan international
et sur le plan national de la diversité
culturelle de la spécificité française
et on ne s'est pas aperçu des
conséquences que cela pouvait comporter
notamment pour des jeunes certes il y
avait des abus
ces abus et est dont beaucoup de grandes
entreprises
suivez mon regard assumer une part de
responsabilité et qu'il fallait corriger
indiscutablement mais les conséquences
sur un certain nombre de jeunes artistes
étaient ont été mal appréciée
à l'origine il ya eu à leur île mais ça
c'est un autre problème c'est une
décision qui a été prise par les
organisations syndicales c'est pas la
responsabilité du gouvernement mais le
problème se pose est donc j'ai demandé
au gouvernement immédiatement de prendre
tous les contacts nécessaires dans le
cadre de la concertation indispensables
pour trouver la solution aux problèmes
qui sont posés notamment pour les jeunes
artistes après vous avez évoqué les
chercheurs ça c'est aussi un vrai
problème
il ya eu ce malaise et cette réaction
à quoi est elle due d'abord à un mal un
malaise dû à l'insuffisance des moyens
consacrés à la recherche et ça c'est un
malaise justifier dès 2002 j'avais
indiqué que la recherche étant je dirais
le moteur principal de la croissance et
de l'avenir
il fallait que la france fasse un effort
important est qu'elle atteigne avant
2010 3% de sa richesse nationale
affectés à la recherche
on a probablement pris du retard dans
cette temps ce domaine pour des raisons
tenant tôt contraintes budgétaires elles
mêmes issues de l'insuffisance de
croissance quand il y avait de la
croissance il ya trois quatre cinq ans
c'était plus facile maintenant c'est
évidemment plus difficile c'est vrai que
lyon pau tous les pays européens
il fallait donc répondre à ce besoin
notamment parce qu'ils étaient exprimées
mais surtout parce qu'il est conforme à
l'intérêt national
d'où l'idée d'une grande loi
d'orientation et de programmation de la
recherche
et puis il y avait un problème
spécifique était un problème de
répartition des postes entre les postes
statutaires et les postes contractuels
et ce problème devrait être réexaminé
j'ai demandé aussi au gouvernement de
réexaminer ce problème de poste
mais ça ce n'est pas là l'essentiel ce
problème sera réglé
mais l'essentiel c'est que l'on fasse
une réflexion approfondie sur notre
recherche et notamment notre recherche
universitaire qui manque de moyens alors
qu'elle est essentielle il ya là un
effort particulier à faire c'est une des
missions du nouveau gouvernement
il y a le problème de la réforme
probablement l'adaptation et de notre
système institutionnel et notamment de
nos grands établissements de recherche
ça ça suppose une concertation réflexion
approfondie pour voir comment on peut
moderniser et rendre plus dynamique plus
efficace cette recherche
il ya bien entendu la loi de
programmation qui doit prévoir les
moyens nécessaires pour les années qui
viennent et il y a enfin mais une
nécessité absolue d'une augmentation
très sensible de la recherche privée qui
en france est très insuffisante par
rapport à ce que l'on voit dans tous les
grands pays il ya donc un problème
général dans le cherche dans toute cette
affaire chercheurs intermittents
professeur vous avez été choqué de voir
qu'on disait que vous faisiez sont deux
guerres à l'intelligence sous prétexte
ou sont des catégories qui ne votent pas
pour vous habituellement fait partie de
la polémique et je ne me choque pas
polémique
la polémique s'est aussi je vous le dit
tout à l'heure l'un des ressorts de la
démocratie quand faut-il ne pas en
abuser
et encore faut-il comprendre une chose
essentielle c'est que en france nous
n'avons pas la culture vraiment du
dialogue
et ça c'est vrai pour tout le monde
c'est vrai pour le gouvernement ces
prêts pour les organisations
professionnelles ou syndicales nous
n'avons pas une culture de dialogue nous
avons spontanément pour des raisons que
l'on peut historiquement que x
qu'est une culture de la fronde ça c'est
une voie là une réforme qui est
essentiel faire petit à petit entrer
dans l'esprit des gens en france ce qui
est déjà entré dans la plupart des pays
qui nous entourent savoir que c'est par
le dialogue ce qui suppose que chacun
fasse un effort en ce domaine
les dirigeants syndicales et
professionnelles et c'est que le
dialogue est toujours meilleur que la
fronde est ce que vous allez y arriver
pour une réforme très importante qui est
attendu la réforme de
l'assurance-maladie de voir ce que vous
allez la différer ou est ce qu'elle va
tenir les délais que vous lui avez un
parti vous savez là nous sommes sur un
point tout à fait essentiel pour
l'avenir de notre pays et de notre pacte
social tel que nous l'estimons
nécessaire aujourd'hui le niveau des
déficits et la non maîtrise des dépenses
conduite à un déficit de l'assurance
maladie un maîtrisable et dont les
conséquences ne peuvent pas ne pas être
dramatiques
c'est à dire c'est la mise en cause même
de l'assurance maladie qui qui doit être
consigné ses sa mise en cause a donc les
urgences oui or quand on met en cause
l'assurance maladie on sait très bien ce
qui se passe
les riches peut naturellement conserve
les moyens d'assumer leurs
responsabilités en matière de leur santé
ou celle de leurs proches
et naturellement ce sont les pauvres qui
n'ont pas les moyens
d'ailleurs pour eux qui avaient été
faits le système le pacte social de 1945
donc l'assurance maladie la sécurité
sociale manger vers l'assurance maladie
en particulier c'est un domaine tout à
fait vitale pour la nation finale il
faut donc faire ce qui est nécessaire
alors ce qui est celle liée à leur faire
croire madame chabot avec un esprit
quatre idées simples la première c'est
la transparence
c'est à dire le dialogue cette
transparence
elle conduit en particulier je le dis
tout de suite a récusé le recours aux
ordonnances ne s'est pas du tout un
domaine où l'on peut opérer par le
recours aux ordonnances et des
l'intention deuxième gouvernement
deuxième principe deuxième c'est qu'il
faut faire évoluer nos comportements
il n'est pas normal que la france soit
le champion du monde en matière de
consommation de médicaments ce n'est pas
normal
il n'est pas normal que par tête
d'habitant les allemands consomment
trois fois moins d'antibiotiques que les
français ce n'est pas normal donc ya un
problème d'évolution de nos
comportements
la maîtrise médicalisée n'a pas mal ça
sera pas facile troisième point c'est
que et il faut un pilote dans l'avion
dans l'avion de l'assurance maladie pour
le moment on a l'impression qu'il n'y en
a pas vraiment les tâches en occupe
peuvent toujours alter venir parfois
pour des raisons qui ne sont pas tout à
fait justifiable des organisations
syndicales et professionnelles ne sont
pas à leur place dans l'esprit et dans
la ligne du pacte social de 1945 le
pilote s'était les partenaires sociaux
bien qu'ici je suis oui ça c'est ce
n'est pas acceptable ce n'est pas
convenable le pilote s'était les
partenaires sociaux et cela doit revenir
s'il n'y a pas d'autre solution et qui
soit conforme à l'intérêt général et je
dirais à la morale l'éthique même de la
protection sociale
c'est pourquoi j'ai demandé au
gouvernement de d'engager les
négociations nécessaires dans ce sens et
puis dernier point il faudra
naturellement prendre des mesures de
redressement
elles n'ont pas encore été décidés du
tout elles sont essentielles elles
seront difficiles
pourquoi j'estime qu'elles doivent être
prises je lui ai dit tout à l'heure dans
la transparence et dans la concertation
c'est la raison pour laquelle comme
l'ont fait la plupart de nos grands
partenaires européens et notamment nos
amis allemands
il est indispensable que les partenaires
sociaux et le gouvernement mais aussi
que la majorité et nos positions sur un
sujet aussi vital pour l'avenir des
français se rassemblent pour discuter
ensemble et ensemble rechercher une
solution
regardez pour la laïcité il ya eu un
grand débat un débat de fond de principe
et finalement on est arrivé à une
solution qui a été approuvée aussi bien
par là l'opposition que par la majorité
quand il ya un grand débat national un
grand enjeu essentiel pour la vie des
français et notamment des plus modestes
il est indispensable de trouver un
accord national le se réfugier
simplement dans la polémique ou dans la
critique n'est pas possible penser que
le n'y a qu'à ou imposer une solution
n'est pas possible non plus donc il ya
là un grand défi le ministre philippe
douste-blazy qui est un homme la fois
d'une grande compétence et d'une grande
sensibilité aura à assumer cette
responsabilité je le répète est
essentielle pour les années qui viennent
je suis sûr qu'il le fera avec beaucoup
de qualités vous imaginez des tables
rondes de travail sur une durée assez
longue d'ailleurs avec des partenaires
de plus c'est long c'est affectif est
assez longue c'est ma mobilité
il faut savoir qu'il y a urgence comme
il y avait urgence à faire la réponse
des retraites
je pris donc tout cela non nous allons
dans le mur tout cela intervient
justement sur un une situation
économique est quand même assez atone
une croissance relativement molle nous a
dit hier l'insee est ce qu'avec cette
petite croissance
ce qu'elle vous paraît suffisante en
tout cas pour résorber les déficits pour
cas plaisir à bruxelles et pour
continuer la baisse des impôts que vous
aviez promise donc je voudrais d'abord
rappeler que la baisse des impôts
et pas un cadeau que je veux faire aux
uns et aux autres
nous y sommes c'est une nécessité c'est
la raison pour laquelle c'était une
promesse nous sommes aujourd'hui l'un
des pays l'un des grands pays les plus
taxés du monde
c'est un handicap formidable à notre
croissance et à notre développe il faut
dire métier il n'y a pas de mystère
si on découvre un si on décourage les
gens on décourage l'initiative la
croissance le développement l'emploi
l'amélioration sociale le progrès social
donc il est essentiel je dirais en tous
les cas de rentrer dans la moyenne au
moins dans la moyenne européenne
donc on continuera l'année prochaine
donc il faudra continuer dans toute la
mesure de nos moyens naturellement et
compte tenu des contraintes qui sont les
nôtres il faudra continuer je le répète
non pas pour faire plaisir aux jeunes ou
aux autres mais parce que c'est vital si
on veut continuer à avoir de l'emploi de
la croissance de l'investissement de la
recherche
c'est indispensable sinon toutes les
forces vives créatrice risque de partir
de gérer comment va-t-on faire pour
rentrer dans les chronos lundi de la
croissance est molle elle est toujours
trop nous on peut en tous les cas
l'espérer toujours meilleur elle est en
voie d'amélioration
il ya une chose qui me qui me chagrine
toujours un peu c'est de voir quel point
nous soulignons en permanence tout ce
qui peut engendrer le pessimisme
quand je dis nous c'est nous tous
d'ailleurs c'est aussi l'une des
caractéristiques françaises ont nourri
le pessimisme sans se rendre compte qu
en nourrissant le pessimisme alors que
nous avons des atouts fantastique que
nous faisons la preuve de notre
savoir-faire dans le monde entier en
nourrissant le pessimisme
naturellement on décourage les gens
décourage d'initiative
des quoi je travaille je ne suis pas
pessimiste je ne le suis pas par nature
et je ne suis pas par conviction et il
n'y a pas aujourd'hui lieu de l'être
on a une reprise insuffisante par
rapport à ce que nous pourrions souhaité
de la croissance mais c'est quand même
une reprise
on observe en europe il faut
l'accompagner tout le souci des
dirigeants européens notamment lors du
dernier conseil qui a eu lieu il ya
quelques jours a été de nous mobiliser
pour essayer de donner une impulsion
ensemble à la croissance on a pu le ca
processus de lisbonne peu importe donner
ensemble une impulsion la croissance
mais c'est essentiel à suffisance
promotion pour permettre de revenir dans
le masque demande russie doit donner à
la croissance il y à un élément capital
c'est d'avoir un certain optimisme
raisonnable et raisonnée mais un certain
optimisme tout ce qui alimente en frange
beaucoup plus qu'ailleurs dans des
conditions d'ailleurs qui sont très mal
comprise à l'étranger je peux en porter
témoignage le pessimisme étonne un
élément supplémentaire de notre que ça
va vous faire de peine et le montré très
pessimiste mais il ya un éléphant qui
participe quand même par l enthousiasme
général c'est l'endettement de la france
qui atteint un chiffre considérable
alors est-ce que la première mission
nicolas sarkozy c'est justement pas de
dire ben on va réduire le déficit et
progressivement comme on s'y est engagé
à respecter les demandes européennes
mais
milliards d'euros d'endettement ça fait
peur il y a deux raisons et c'est un
grand défi que devra relever ce sarkozy
aux finances il y a effectivement laissé
s'accumuler depuis dix ans on a laissé
s'accumuler les dépenses immédiates ou
potentiels celle que l'on était obligé
d'assumer tout de suite et celle que
l'on laissé au suivant le soin d'assumer
et nous sommes arrivés à cette situation
où nos déficits ne sont plus acceptables
pour nos partenaires et où surtout notre
endettement puisque c'est la même chose
l'espace devient telle qu'en réalité
nous reportons sur nos enfants de façon
inacceptable la charge de notre confort
actuel ce n'est pas possible il faut
donc retrouver la maîtrise de ses
dépenses ce qui suppose en particulier
que on regarde très exactement le
rapport coût-efficacité d'un certain
nombre d'actions notamment d'actions
conduites par le gouvernement il ya un
effort à faire
je regardais madame chabot il y a trois
jours trop quatre jours
votre excellente édition où vraiment
croisés mots croisés et c'était très
intéressant et parmi les intervenants il
ya eu un monsieur je ne connaissais
d'ailleurs pas mais qui a exposé avec
beaucoup de force et à l'évidence de
compétences d'ailleurs personne ne l'a
contesté ou de la contredit le fait que
disait-il la perception des impôts en
france et quatre fois plus chère que
dans les autres pays européens
c'est bien ce qu'il a dit exactement
alors je ne cherche pas à faire de
compte deux contre deux
de comparaison mais c'est un exemple
parmi beaucoup de la nécessité qu'il ya
à reprendre en main certain nombre de
mauvaises habitudes à moderniser un
certain nombre de méthodes
si les entreprises privées et qui font
richesse de notre pays et avait accepté
de ne rien changer depuis 30 ans ou 50
hommes là il est certain que la france
aurait pratiquement cessé d'exister
eh bien l'état doit assumer les mêmes
responsabilités ce que disait ce
peut-être que cet expert était tout à
fait juste n'était un exemple parmi
d'autres et c'est très difficile pour
cela aussi il ne faut pas de la
confrontation
il ne faut pas chercher à imposer le
changement d'habitudes souvent si
ancienne qu'on les trouve tout à fait
naturel quand on les assume
il faute du dialogue de la concertation
la raison comment faire que le mot
réforme ne soit pas toujours associé au
mot sacrifice pour l'essentiel en
employant moins ce goût alors qu'est-ce
qu'on parle de mot vous avez employé le
mot de fracture sociale en 95 que vous
avez été élu d'abord parlé de cohésion
sociale cohésion nationale à travers le
ministère de jeunes de jean louis borloo
puisque là vous avez trois ans devant
vous trois ans sans élections qu'est ce
que vous voulez en faire de ces trois
ans avant de remettre votre mandat en
jeu ou de vous retirer
qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez qu'il reste
deux de ses trois ans et une france qui
aura retrouvé tout son dynamisme et qui
par conséquent sera en mesure d'assumer
son pacte social sans les cornées et en
le développant ceci dans un contexte
européen de paix et de démocratie mais
hé hé
lance le problème de la cohésion sociale
que vous avez évoqué une fracture
sociale est un vrai problème en france
n'est bien obligé de constater que
malgré une augmentation très
considérable des dépenses et notamment
des dépenses sociales depuis 10 ans 20
ans peu importe je ne fais pas là
allusion à temps politique
gouvernementale mais un fait social
la pauvreté n'a pas diminué et
l'exclusion non plus c'est un fait
et petit à petit se sont développées
renforcée des ghettos ils sont souvent
des ghettos de la misère
et ça ce n'est pas acceptable en
pourquoi il y a une raison à cela entre
autres c'est que des hommes les femmes
les jeunes qui sont victimes de ce
phénomène
en réalité il faut le reconnaître ne
sont sérieusement et efficacement
défendu par personne ils ne sont pas
dans le système alors naturellement il
provoque un certain nombre de
lamentations jeu c'est un certain nombre
d'observateurs qui ensuite en tire
aucune conséquence ils ne sont pas
réellement et par conséquent il faut
vraiment faire quelque chose si j'ai
souhaité que l'on créé un ministère de
la cohésion sociale qui est en main
l'ensemble des éléments pour agir dans
ce domaine qui va du logement au travail
en passant par l'intégration
la grande faiblesse des dix ans passés
nous n'avons pas eu de politique
d'intégration
en tous les cas une politique très
insuffisante et demi en portons encore
actuellement les consacrer vous êtes
fait si j'ai nommé oui oui je sais bien
mais je n'avais pas pendant les
dernières années
que à 2002 tous les moyens pour agir et
ceux qui ne m'avait pas empêché de dire
les choses mais c'est pas toujours été
écoutés façon aussi souhaitable que je
leur ai imaginé gouvernement précédent
peu importe je ne suis pas en train de
polémique et contre qui que ce soit je
constate donc il est essentiel
aujourd'hui que l'on est une politique
qui nous permettent de réduire par tous
les moyens
concentré entre les mains de quelqu'un
qui peut agir façon coordonnée et
cohérente depuis le logement jusqu'au
travail en passant par l'intégration par
l'ensemble des actions qui peuvent être
conduites pour je dirais déghettoïser
notre société c'est capital alors
puisqu'on arrive au terme de cette
émission donc vous poser une question
étrangères et qui concerne le
remaniement d'hier de retirer dominique
villepin du quai d'orsay et de le
remplacer par l'européen michel barnier
sassou d'une façon un signe amical
vis-à-vis des américains est un signe
vis-à-vis des européens
je te permettez moi de vous dire que
l'on nomme pas en france un ministre des
affaires étrangères pour faire un signe
à quelqu'un on nomme un mais des
affaires étrangères pour conduire sous
l'impulsion du président de la
république responsable éminent dans ce
domaine une politique étrangère
alors le fait que monsieur barnier soit
une autorité dans le domaine européen et
un plus indiscutable
l'homme qui connaît parfaitement le
fonctionnement des mécanismes européens
est un homme qui est profondément
européen et c'est un homme par
conséquent qui pourra au moment si
difficile de la réforme des institutions
européennes et de l'élargissement qui
pourra conduire les intérêts de la
france de la meilleure façon je lui fais
tout à fait confiance dans ce domaine
et pour le reste je vous suis tout de
suite que la politique de la france ne
change pas elle et émanent
essentiellement du président de la
république et tant que je serai là cette
politique ne changera pas alors je suis
président on vous entendu depuis tout à
l'heure avec avec patrick poivre d'arvor
non corrigée demandé au gouvernement de
faire un certain nombre d'adaptations
dresser sa feuille de route donné des
perspectives et beaucoup de français se
disent régulièrement mais pourquoi le
président de la république ne parle-t-il
pas plus souvent parce qu'au fond ça
irait peut-être mieux et c'est sa
fonction de nous dire où on va il ya un
manque et on a l'impression que vous
occupez surtout des dossiers
internationaux à la safer étrangères et
la défense dont dépend pour une large
part rôle et la place de la france dans
le monde
sa capacité à défendre ses intérêts et
de façon imminente
le rôle du chef de l'état et je suis
efforcé de porter cette voie aussi haut
que possible parce que c'est en france
la voie de la paix du droit de la
justice du respect des autres et du
dialogue des cultures et je continuerai
alors pour me dit que je devrai
m'exprimer davantage vous avez peut-être
raison mais bill english as tu écrives
je sais vous avez peut-être réseau
voudrais pas qu'on dise non plus que le
président de la république
se mêle de tout gouvernement qui est
responsable et qui assume cette
responsabilité
c'est quand il est légitime que je donne
un certain nombre d'orientations
il ne m'appartient pas de conduire la
politique quotidienne du gouvernement en
revanche je voudrais dire que au delà
des compétences naturelles dans notre
constitution du chef de l'état et qui
sont grandes et je voudrais dire que en
2002 j'ai pris tout à fait conscience de
la réalité politique qui a donné le
résultat dont vous vous souvenez et qui
me conduit à mettre au premier rang de
ses préoccupations et de cette vocation
du chef de l'état dans notre pays
la défense des valeurs de la république
et tout simplement parce que les
français doivent être fiers de la france
les français doivent se rassembler
autour des valeurs qui font la france ça
c'est essentiel
et ça c'est un peu aussi et plus encore
depuis 2002 tel en tous les cas que je
l' ai ressenti le rôle du chef de l'état
là il est presque 21h au nom d'un
d'arlette chabot et de noter les
filateurs je vous remercie monsieur
prière vous remercie voilà pour cette
intervention en direct de l'elysée avant
de refermer ce journal nous allons
entendre de réaction et un commentaire
le vôtre gérard leclerc vous nous avez
rejoint un bon soir car il ya des
enseignements à tirer de cette
intervention est qu un président qui
plonge un peu dans la mêlée et des
annonces très concrètes finalement il a
vraiment répondu aux questions que les
gens se posent alors par exemple le
président at il tenu tirer les leçons
des régionales et bien oui il a coûté
attentivement et entendu l'inquiétude
l'impatience et le mécontentement est at
il dit le gouvernement doit être à
l'offensive sur l'emploi la croissance
et doit être attentif à la justice
sociale
alors pourquoi avoir choisi de maintenir
jean pierre raffarin et bien at il dit
j'ai fait le choix de la constance et de
derrière détermination
et jean pierre raffarin est en harmonie
avec les deux caps que jacques chirac
avait fixé à son arrivée au pouvoir à
savoir redonner des fondations à la
république et puis faire accepter les
évolutions de la société qui sont
nécessaires mais qui doivent être faites
là encore at il souligné dans une
exigence de justice sociale
et puis là jacques chirac a vraiment
donné une sorte de feuille de route au
gouvernement il rentre et on peut dire
d'enfants dans la mêlée absolument il a
détaillé les corrections que le
gouvernement devait apporter à son
action par exemple sur la réduction des
droits des chômeurs la fameuse à essay
c'est bien il a dit il a demandé au
gouvernement de suspendre ses traits
forme de la ss sur les intermittents et
bien il faut réévaluer la situation des
jeunes artistes la recherche un effort
particulier doit être fait et notamment
au niveau des créations de postes si la
revendication blesure absolument
l'assurance maladie certes il faut la
réformer mais dans la transparence et
jacques chirac a dit qu'il ne fallait
pas passer par les ordonnances comme le
souhaitait le faire le gouvernement
et puis sur les déficits là aussi il
faut retrouver la maîtrise des dépenses
publiques mais toujours dans le dialogue
et la concertation
plus généralement donc jacques chirac a
plaidé pour l'action rien n'a été fait
depuis dix ans est il souvent
l'ati souvent répété et puis il s'en est
pris à ceux qui nourrissent le
pessimisme alors at il dit que la
reprise est là et qu'il faut
l'accompagner
voilà un président de la république qui
souhaitait effectivement rentrer dans le
concret c'est ce que retient pour le
parti socialiste julien dray notamment
sur la suspension de la réforme de
l'allocation spécifique de solidarité en
écoute julien dray semblerait que le
président la république se rende compte
tout d'un coup que finalement elle était
injuste bon sens nouveau bon à prendre
pour ceux qui sont victimes de cela pour
été victimes de cette mesure mais sur le
fond comprend pas que l'essentiel de ce
qui a été fait depuis 18 mois a été
vécue comme une agression une remise en
cause donc on nous explique tout vous
qu'il faut faire des réformes
bon on s'attribue le principe de la
réforme mais c'est pas ça qui est en
cause tous je veux dire c'est contenu de
ce qui a été fait jusqu'à maintenant et
là on voit bien qu'il ne veut pas
changer c'est donc bien dire que le jeu
de chaises musicales servies à brouiller
les pistes mais que sur le fond de la
politique on va pas revenir en arrière
voilà réaction à l'udf maintenant on
écoute andré santini qui se dit
satisfait du mea culpa en quelque sorte
exprimée par le président de la
république et qui attend la suite andré
santini le réquisitoire qu'il a
prononcée contre monsieur raffarin 2 et
passionnant finalement il ya eu erreur
surtout je me permettrai de rappeler que
l'udf pendant le débat budgétaire avait
buté contre la baisse symbolique des 3 %
en matière fiscale s'étaient élevées
contre la réduction de l'allocation
spécifique de solidarité avait demandé
qu' on ne méprise pas les chercheurs et
aujourd'hui qu'il y ait un geste pour
les intermittents et bien je suis
heureux de constater que tout cela va
faire partie du programme de raffarin
iii
voilà pour ce très large chapitre
politique aujourd'hui évidemment avec
cette intervention du chef de l'état une
image encore avant de se séparer une
image de sport pour vous rappeler
qu'hier soir la france 1
confire match sans éclat à rotterdam 0 0
face aux pays bas et très peu
d'occasions de but en revanche pour le
futur adversaire des bleus à l'euro
l'angleterre vers la soirée a été bien
pire défaite 1 0 face à la suède on peut
signaler aussi que les tchèques ont été
battus par la r21 l'allemagne gagné 3 0
face à la belgique l'espagne a battu le
danemark 2 0
ces rencontres amicales de préparation à
l'euro 2004 fin de ce journal
merci de l'avoir suivi tout de suite la
météo patrice drevet pour un round
valérie maurice 21h15 envoyé spécial
guilaine chenu et françoise joly au
sommaire notamment fumeurs et
dépendances et puis haïti la tourmente
23h15 campus la france est-elle
réformable guillaume durand reçoit
notamment alain minc
demain à 13 heures daniel bilalian à 21
h le week end vous retrouver béatrice
schönberg
on se quitte sur ces images de la flamme
olympique première étape du tour du
monde
athènes est en raison du vent la gorge
c'est peut-être quelques minutes ça ne
m'empêchera pas de poursuivre son
périple avant de revenir
en août prochain en grèce allait